Tickets on sale now dude catch tickets
on sale now dude tickets on sale now
dude
hey what's up everyone jamie and i are here to
tell you that you can start buying tickets for
spider-man no way home starting on spider monday
no you mean cyber monday yeah i mean it's also
known as cyber monday i see what you're doing look
why can't it be electro monday well because i was
trying to do like a phonetics thing i got to go
check this out buy you tickets for spider-man no
way home on electro monday ah it doesn't really
get point across doesn't it nah it doesn't really
might not monday it is get your tickets for
spider-man no way home on november 29th cyber
night exactly on spider monday and on electro
monday sony throws in a 75-inch 4k tv for us too
as well apparently word they just if they
keep scrolling it says and tom and jamie get
two seven it does say that down it does say that
but they don't want to scroll because they don't
want to you know what they want to surprise us
right that's what it is it's a surprise exactly
just so you know sony's not actually going to
be giving away free tvs but you should still go
get your tickets for spider-man no way home
Welcome back everyone this will be
my new spider-man no way home video
more like spider-man no way you're going to get
those tickets they just put tickets on sale and
it crashed every major ticketing website so
hopefully you were lucky and you managed to
get a couple tickets but don't worry i'll be doing
giveaways for movie tickets for the entire month
the other big thing you may have seen this
morning is amy pascal talking about what
their plans are for the future of tom hall
and spider-man in the mcu in their next
big spider-man trilogy she basically confirmed
all of our big theories so we'll break it all down
if you are brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos like i said we're
doing a giveaway for imax tickets for the movie
all you have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the trailers
on the video what i'll do is i'll talk about the
brand new trailer footage then i'll talk about
what amy pascal and the sony people revealed about
the future of mcu spider-man because it's actually
a really big deal but during the new footage
spider-man is actually face timing with ned lee's
this isn't just for the promo this is actually
footage from the movie he's face timing ned leeds
while he and mj are on top of the queensborough
bridge and it's just a montage of wtf reactions
like they're all just freaking out dude
dude the scene is happening when the nypd
helicopter catches them on top of the
queensborough bridge on their way back to queens
it's part of the larger chase scene of him and
mj webb slinging through all the buildings in
the beginning of all the trailers then he takes
her underground into the subway tunnels to escape
the police it almost gets her squash just swinging
around trying to avoid the oncoming subway
trains just making sure that she will never never
want to web sling around with him ever again like
if she seems scared during the spider-man far from
home post-credits scene swinging around with
him just you wait it's gonna get so much worse
and if you were laughing because of that weird
trailer edit with the phantom andrew garfield
lizard punch from the last big trailer sony
and marvel are actually leaning into the andrew
garfield tobey maguire jokes in their new promos
now this is now spider monday and to celebrate i
have a really big announcement but first let me
bring in two very special friends to help out
i mean it's only right we are your best
friends right it makes sense for us to join
this announcement of course i mean who else would
it be who else could he possibly be referring to
indeed which other two people could the entire
internet have been obsessing over for the past
year i think it's smart for them to just
lean into the crash on something like this
like everybody kind of knows that something is
going on with toby maguire andrew garfield in the
movie we might not know exactly what's going
on but we know that something's going on but
the real talk this morning the brand new feature
that amy pascal did longtime spider-man producer
basically laid out marvel and sony's plans for
the entire future of the solo spider-man movies
with tom holland in a new trilogy in live-action
miles morales so i'll explain that in detail
i'm sure kevin feige is in the middle of
becoming a whole new meme after she spilled
all the beans this morning now it all makes
sense curb your feige i think one of the things
if you didn't see the brand new interview that
she did this morning what happened is that amy
pascal confirmed pretty much all my theories
probably a lot of theories that you all had too
about marvel and sony bringing tom holland back
for a new trilogy of solo spider-man movies and
larger spider-verse spin-off movie plans i even
did a video a couple weeks ago after tom holland
did a very similar type of interview giving
all these hints about things that amy pascal
just confirmed about what the next trilogy
of movies would be so if it wasn't clear amy
pascal confirmed a new full trilogy of tom hall
and spider-man movies with marvel the only thing
that's definitely going to be different is that
they're going to get a new director because john
watts the person who directed spider-man no way
home in all the solo spider-man movies at marvel
is now going to be directing the brand new mcu
fantastic four reboot franchise i do have some
theories about how that's going to connect with
the next spider-man trilogy so i'll talk about
that in a second too but amy pascal basically said
that they're going to start working on spider-man
4 really soon i got posted this early this morning
and people are like what are you talking about is
this toby maguire spider-man 4 no this is about
tom hall and spider-man 4. give me rent you'll
get your rent when you fix this damn door and
because amy pascal said that they're starting work
on it really soon i think that soft confirmation
that tom holland has already signed a brand new
contract for all these upcoming movies he just
did this really funny interview where they point
blank asked him if he had signed a new contract
and this was his funny way of soft confirming
giggling next question
even when he's trying to do the no comment answer
he still gives everything away we know exactly
what's going on right now just based on what
they've said about the spider-man characters these
characters in the whole subplot with him trying to
get into mit university during spider-man no way
home the next trilogy sounds like it definitely
will be spider-man in college it might not wind up
being mit iron man went to mit mcu riri williams
right now in the black panther 2 movie is going
to mit so mit is a pretty big mcu location but i'm
actually hoping that he doesn't get in there and
has to go to either empire state like in the
comics or the tobey maguire spider-man movies
which is in the new york city area or he goes
to the future foundation and they spend some of
that new spider-man trilogy spider-man 4 5 and 6
crossing over with the new fantastic four movies
like a very common theory that everyone has is
that the fantastic four reed richards in the
future foundation are the ones who bought the old
avengers tower from iron man and we'll see that
for the first time in the new fantastic four movie
like i said john watts long-time mcu spider-man
movie director is doing the new fantastic four
trilogy of movies so it makes sense that marvel
would want to have some crossover between the new
fantastic four franchise in the next spider-man
trilogy and those characters have a long history
of crossovers in the comics if you're not a big
comic book reader the fantastic four literally
appeared in amazing spider-man number 1 the very
first issue of his solo comic book after amazing
fantasy we saw the new avengers tower redesign
in the spider-man far from home post-credits scene
and there was a huge fantastic four easter egg
here with all these numbers i did several videos
about those fantastic four easter eggs after the
movie came out a couple years ago so i'll link
those in the description below so it just seems
like there's a lot of spider-man fantastic four
crossover energy happening in the background
as for venom crossover and live-action miles
morales there's a rumor that one of the spider-man
no way home post credit scenes will be the venom
symbiote getting stuck in the mcu universe and
eddie brock getting sent back to his original
universe so that marvel can do a version of a
spider-man symbiote saga in this new trilogy
of movies either just one movie or stretch it
out over multiple new films in the trilogy like he
gets the symbiote then eventually gets rid of the
symbiote will that happen in one movie or will
that happen over the course of a couple movies
and at the same time set up live-action miles
morales for his own trilogy like he mentors
a new version of spider-man tom holland even
talked about wanting to do that in new movies
and eventually miles morales goes on to his own
spin-off solo movies that are separate from tom
hall and spider-man movies so now i'm also kind
of thinking that we'll probably get a very small
miles morales easter egg or scene at the end of
spider-man no way home or a post-credit scene
easter egg just setting him up like hey we're
doing this in the next trilogy and speaking of
miles morales and spider-man into the spider-verse
2 amy pascal said that they would have a new
teaser trailer for that to show up pretty soon
maybe before the end of the year or maybe sometime
early next year because we do have two spider-man
movies coming out within a couple months of each
other no way home and morbius is coming out in
january so a bunch of trailers for all that stuff
coming really soon and if you missed it there's a
spider-man freshman year disney plus series that
they're doing for tom holland's mcu spider-man
i already did a trailer video for that so i'll
link that below in the description too it is a
really good time to be a spider-man fan right now
there's so many spider-man projects let me know
in the comments though what do you want them to do
with the new spider-man trilogy and movies my full
hawkeye episode 3 video we'll post this wednesday
after they release it there's a whole bunch
of daredevil stuff happening during that
and you can click here for my new spider-man
sinister 6 trailer video they just released and
click here for that venom let there be carnage
deleted scene for noel god of the symbiotes
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!